you kept leader Nigel Farage joining us
now live from Sheffield we're so sorry
for all the confusion mr. Faraj a few
technical issues our bad glad you're
still there talk to us about your
posters that you've launched who are
they aimed at yeah there's a series of
posters the posters deal with the issue
of nationality the fact that the
European flag
indeed the European Union is now imposed
on our passports they deal would cost
the fact that membership of this club
costs us fifty five million pounds a day
they deal with the fact that now 75% of
our laws aren't made here they're made
by the institutions of the EU and so
we've lost our democracy and yes it
deals with open borders the fact we have
a complete open border to Southern and
Eastern Europe that we now discriminate
against people from India and New
Zealand in favor of Romania and Bulgaria
and we have no limit on the number of
people that can come to this country and
that doesn't make sense and what's
really interesting is that 77% of
British people in a recent survey said
they believe we've got to get a degree
of control back over our borders don't
get bogged down in figures remember what
happened to Mr Clegg when he did that
let's talk about the other poster one of
the other posters that you've got the
unlimited cheap labour one yeah what are
you trying to say here what we're saying
is that things now in Italy in Spain
within the euro zone are so dire that if
you look at the migration figures for
last year you see most of the in Greece
nearly all of the increase in fact came
from those countries now I'm very sorry
for people down there youth unemployment
in Greece 60 percent and not too far
away from it in Spain as well and yet we
have no control if things get worse in
the eurozone we have zero control over
the number of people that can come to
Britain and that doesn't make sense not
just in the jobs perspective but also
from primary schools health care and
everything else all we're saying is this
we want to have an immigration policy
that has a degree of control over
numbers and quality
how can it be unlimited cheap labor
though when we've got a minimum wage
that you have to get whether you are
British or Spanish or any other European
Eastern European or whatever is 631 an
hour well I mean what's actually
happened to the minimum wage that in
many cases it's now become the maximum
way
because in many industries that probably
will be paying more now they've been
able big employers particularly to force
everyone down to that minimum wage level
and what we're saying is this is that
for a lot of people who work in this
country they have seen wage compression
over the course of the last ten years
they're their real take-home pay going
down at a time when the gas but is still
going up okay so but just to clarify you
think that British workers should have
preferential treatment when it comes to
being offered jobs that are available
well I don't think we should have a
complete open door to the labor market
in this country from the European Union
where we make no decision at all over
numbers or skills or the quality of
people have come and that's why this
stunning seventy seven percent of people
say they want something to be done but
do you think the British workers should
have preparation of preferential
treatment when it comes to being off for
jobs in the United Kingdom I think I
think it's the job of the British
government to make sure that it puts
British people and their interests first
absolutely about that was no question
yes and that's why people vote they vote
I mean I mean the Labour Party the
Labour Party historically was there to
look after working communities in this
country and it's given all of that up in
favour of an open door to Southern and
Eastern Europe but isn't that racist I
don't think it is no I don't think it is
I think it can be deemed as such in any
way but we've never in our history had a
complete open door and now we have one
to 485 million people I don't think in
terms of common sense that really adds
up but if you are a racist it according
to the Oxford English Dictionary it
means that you are have or showing the
belief that a particular race is
superior to another and presumably if
you're saying that British people should
have jobs above East Europeans you're
suggesting that they're superior and as
a result that's racist well actually
this is a big argument in London amongst
the afro-caribbean community 50% of
whom's youngsters haven't got jobs and
that same survey that was done recently
showed over 60% of the settled ethnic
minorities in this country also believe
we've got to have some degree of control
so this crosses all boundaries
this country okay but you getting bogged
down in the figures again and as I said
remember what happens to mr. Cleg when
he did that I've given you the
definition of racist you tell me what
you thought about the fact that British
workers should have a superior chance of
getting a job
above European workers whether they're
from Eastern Europe or whatever and that
is quite simply a racist comment no it
isn't it is the job of a British
government firstly to defend the realm
and secondly to put the interests of the
people that live in this country first
that's what we should be doing and I'm
afraid we've turned our backs on that
over the course of the last few years
which has led to much much unhappiness
among millions of families what should
happen to East Europeans who are working
here at the moment well there are many
of course that have come here and done
incredibly well there are others that
have come here and haven't done
incredibly well what is for certain is
that if you have an oversupply in the
labour market particularly the unskilled
labour market you force down wages and
you make it much harder particular
school leavers to get their foot on the
rung of the labour market place they
just like to do the rest so they
shouldn't be here so they shouldn't be
here they should leave so that those
jobs could be given to somebody else to
a British obsessed
I haven't argued that well I haven't
argued we should retrospectively change
any laws at all what I am saying is here
on in we need to take back control and
ultimately I mean the place to really
debate this is going to be a referendum
in this country at the moment ed
Miliband says he won't give us a
referendum and part of our campaign is
to go for labour votes in the north of
England particularly to force labour if
he does become the next prime minister
it's giving the British people a choice
immigration on this scale has led to
increasing segregation in our towns and
cities but worst of all what it's done
socially it has left I'm afraid a white
working class effectively as an
underclass and that I think is a
disaster for society you know that
obviously that's that's what you said
during one of the Europe debates with Mr
Clegg so you're suggesting that we have
created in this
a white underclass a white working-class
underclass I didn't say it was so dia
that if you remember the next sentence I
asked it was about particular in South
London the afro-caribbean community
having been forced into the same
position yes we have disadvantaged the
life chances of many people in this
country from all backgrounds how would
you describe a racist I don't know you
tell me I don't know I'm asking you well
I don't know I know we're running a
party I'm here in Yorkshire the number
two on our list is am Jeb Bashir born in
Pakistan raised in Bradford he's a
businessman he's standing for you clip
and he knows that he signed up as all
our candidates have done to make a
non-sectarian non racist party committed
to putting the interests of the British
people first that's what it's about but
you can't describe what a racist means
to you somebody that someone that
discriminates on those grounds that's
not us there are other choices on the
ballot paper for people that feel like
that mercifully I don't think they're
going to get many votes I'm just looking
at what if we can talk about the reason
that we got you on obviously was talking
about your manifesto and Lucy vade in
Devon I'll be voting you KITT because
they're the only party listening to what
people want very pretty girl she ticks
all the boxes why did you choose her
well she is a member of our party and
has been for some years and she works
for us in our head office in London do
you think you should have no problem
with her I have no problem with a retort
under dweller you should have made that
clearer on your manifesto so I can't
really win with you can i on the one
hand you're saying that we are talking
about a white working-class in Britain
and secondly when I tell you but working
directly for me is a girl who's half
Indian you've got a problem with that I
don't think you do sighs let me find out
what the criticism is I'll tell you what
my it's not a criticism it's merely an
observation that it's for our viewers to
decide to make their own minds up the
point is when you see that picture that
beautiful girl you don't
actually say that she is a member of you
Kip what you need it looks as though she
is a very intelligent beautiful member
of society and she has decided that she
wants to vote you kit you have to go
onto Twitter before you can see that she
is an Events Manager for you Kip and an
assistant to you well I don't think I
don't think you'd ask this question of
the Labour Party for Lib Dems on the
Conservatives who often have group
pictures you know the leader were 25
people standing behind them and you've
never asked a CV of any of those have
you I think I have actually and you know
what when I have later on they said
wouldn't ask this of the Tories and when
I have the Tories on they say you
wouldn't ask this of Labor you just
becoming a mainstream politician no I'm
sorry I'm not going to have that you
know the fact the fact that Lizzie vade
is half Indian and works for us is as
far as we're concerned a non-issue of
course it's an issue you have to be you
have to be open and transparent and say
oh and by the way I work for you kick I
don't I don't see any reason another
topic she's somebody in our promotional
material is gonna vote you kick she
joined you care she got a job in you yet
because she believes in what we stand
for what earth is wrong with exactly
what on earth is wrong with what so why
don't you actually say that in your
documentation I don't see the need sorry
I don't see the need you are you see
you're going down this you're going down
this media route I know do you want us
to say the religion of all of our
candidates or do you want us to say
we're living in the United Kingdom
wherever we come from whatever religion
we are we are part of this country I'm
all in this together that's our message
and you seem to be wanting to segment
people out if in doubt always blame the
media that's what I find is a very
useful way of going about it was that's
what Mary McLeod did when she was on the
program the other day and I wondered if
I could ask you how you think you're
going to do in the elections well I
don't know I mean if you look at the
opinion polls the last half a dozen
labour a clearly in the lead with the
Tories trailing in third you know we are
going to spend a lot of our time
resource and effort in the big cities in
the north of England in the big labor
voting areas because we know in a very
large chunk of old labour does not like
the fact that we're controlled by the
institutions of Brussels and you know if
that's how they feel there isn't much
point of them voting the new labor is
that fancy being an MP I don't know
let's get may the 22nd out of the way
first it's a European election labour of
the front-runners labour the bookmakers
favourites to win our job and with this
launch here in Sheffield today is to
challenge that over the course of the
next four weeks